what's up guys so one of my favorite
things on YouTube besides sleepy kitty
videos and cute puppies and possums and
animals and all the pretty little ponies
is slowmo
[Music]
videos
oh
[Music]
w
I stopped by the pop spot booth at
VidCon and they had this entire wall of
props and a camera set up up where you
can basically do anything you want in
slow-mo so for my slow-mo video I chose
to throw a pie in somebody's face do
anybody want to get hit in the face of
the pie let's go let's
go and have Nerf guns shot at me I
actually have a fear of Nerf guns so
this is actually slightly terrifying for
me let's do it 3 2
1 oh God I hate it
he thanks for watching I hope you guys
enjoyed the slow-mo video I want to know
from you guys what should I do in slowo
next because I have a plan I'm going to
show up at the pop spot office with all
of your printed out comments all of the
ones that aren't vulgar or disgusting or
illegal and I'm going to be like this
I'm going to knock I'm going to knock on
the door hi hello it's just you guys
shot Nerf guns at me can we make another
video please so yeah that's my plan if
you guys want to check out their Channel
check it out here I'll see you guys in
my next video which happens to be every
day because I'm posting videos every day
for Vlog every day in August those are
on my other Austine and Austin's iPhone
Channel also don't forget about my uh
Austine reviews Channel I'm posting a
video there every Friday with a show
called IG like and my gaming channel I
play video games because I love to play
video games I want to go
[Music]
bye